♫ Ooh, we're unstopable
♫ We're unstopable
(sleek electronic music)
- What's going to happen with retail
over the next seven to ten years
is going to be so massively
disruptive that I wonder,
you want to talk about catching,
you want to talk about catching a trend.
It's the conversation
of the next 20 years.
I mean, the Lord &
Taylor's, the Toys'R'Us,
these are the previews,
these are not anomalies.
These are previews.
I mean, J.C. Penny and Sears have
zero chance of being
alive, this is not a, zero.
- And this is where they jump off.
They think this is a story
of internet verus stores.
- Correct.
- No.
- It's not.
- Okay, it's much deeper than that.
- No.
You start getting into Lord
& Taylor's, and Macy's,
and Bloomingdale's, they've
got double pressure.
They've got the internet
issue, they've got
brands going direct to
consumer, and more importantly,
the brands, their vendors
are clearly our competitor,
but their a double edge sword.
I think Ralph Lauren is going to be
out of business in 15 years.
Like, these brands are not
marketing in Instagram,
they still think it's
print and other bullshit.
- (mumbles)
- And Uniqlo, it's, it's, by the way,
being in Singapore right after
the Uniqlo meeting and
seeing Uniqlo everywhere.
- That, see, is almost two dimensional.
You have the stores that are
like the Sak's of the world
that you ask, what's
their reason for being?
- That's right.
- And how do they reinvent themselves.
And you have a brick and
mortar versus internet,
versus you know, how do you
provide value to the customer?
Then you have the brands.
The brands actually can survive.
You know, some of them
are doing really well.
- 100%
- You know, the question there
- They have the most up side.
- Yeah, they can do very well, if in fact,
they learn how to market
to this new consumer.
- Right, the problem is.
- The old brands have a hard time.
- Yeah, I mean, the problem is, you know,
whether you're old or new,
it's just your behavior, right?
- Yeah.
- I always tell people, I'm like, look,
there's 68 year old executives who are
a hell of a lot more in
tune to what's going on
that 26 year olds that I know.
Like, it's unbelievable how, this is
a game right now of have and have nots.
- Oh, I call it the winners and losers.
- That's it.
- Same thing.
Spotify.
- I'm a big believer.
Spotify I love.
You know when you
- My kids, see, people have to talk
to is the next gen people
because my son (mumbles).
- Yeah, you're too old, we need to find.
- Yeah, but that's when, you
have to keep trending up.
- No, can I tell you why Spotify, though?
It's actually not because kids listen
to it, or anything of that nature.
There's not a lot of
companies on earth that have
that many credit cards
getting recurring revenue
each month, their ability to add OTT.
Spotify tomorrow starts doing videos on,
if Spotify tomorrow did Behind the Music,
and did one hour documentaries of every
emerging artist, they would get an extra
ten dollars a month from
everybody as an OTT.
- Why don't you talk to them,
have you talked to them?
- I have some real ideas for them.
(upbeat piano music)
- Let's go.
I think there's an over-estimation,
an over-focus on hustle,
work your face off,
which I'm very proud of
and very passionate about,
but I don't think there's as much focus on
you know, empathy, and gratitude, and
give more than you take, and perspective
which is stop focusing on dumb shit.
So, I was a little
strategic on the sneaker.
Minnesota, middle America, you know,
I have a funny idea.
I want my book event in Minnesota
during Super Bowl weekend,
to be the biggest event attended.
Because that's just funny and ridiculous.
So, we will be doing
that, so be prepared for
Saturday, February 3rd in Minnesota,
a ridiculous book launch.
If you're in the Minnesota area, if you're
flying into Minnesota, if
you want to be a part of
amassing thousands of
people into one place
so that everybody's like,
what football legend is there?
No, this is Gary V.'s book party.
I want to upend and disrupt Super Bowl.
So, let's do that.
Fill out the form if you
want to be part of the crew
to help, not because you just want to help
because you're going to be in Minnesota
and you can drive people to the event.
Or I've got some idea how.
Hey, Alex.
How are you?
- How soon is (mumbles)?
- Vayner nation, Alex is here.
(laughing)
It's over ambition and
substantial humility,
and so I've been able to
articulate, at least for me,
in a comfortable manner
in, like, clouds and dirts.
Like, have big goals, like, go for it.
Be smart, really be thoughtful,
but always be humble
and execute and stay in the trenches.
Always be a practitioner in your craft.
Those things matter to me.
What matters at the end
of the day is if you agree
with me binarily, that
it's happening here,
now the question becomes, what
are you going to do about it?
First thing you need to
do is, everybody in here
needs to take a step back and get
really self aware really quickly.
Because self awareness and empathy are the
two pillars that will make you successful.
These are two things I do that nobody sees
because of my persona, because of other
alpha characteristics I
have, they're the disguised
superpowers that have
gotten me here today.
But the reality is, a long time ago,
through amazing parenting and the
serendipity of being an
immigrant at the right time,
I got real self aware
real fast, and started
triple-downing on what
I was, verus pandering
to everybody else.
And so, the security and confidence
and all the other things
that were put into me
allowed me to be good at this
game for the last ten years.
And the reason I'm stressing such a E Q,
kind of fluffy thing to
you, it is the framework
that will allow you to be successful.
It is strategy.
Either you have the right strategy,
or you have the wrong one.
Too many kids under 30
want to get there so fast,
and it breaks them because they short cut,
and they create the vulnerabilities that
don't allow them to get there.
So, when I just looked my
18 year old self in the face
and said, your intuitions are right.
Do this, do that, exactly
right, you'll be real happy.
You got it.
Thank you, guys.
(audience applauding)
(mellow music)
- Okay, bye bye, alright, bye bye.
Hey, bro.
- Sorry to bug you, man, how are you?
- No worries, how are you?
- I'm well.
I just moved here from
Indiana on Thursday.
- Congrats.
- Thank you.
I was hoping to maybe
get some time from you,
whenever you've got some free time,
sit down and B.S. with you.
- Okay, well, you do me a favor.
Send me an email right now.
- Okay.
- In the title, put I'm
the guy from Indiana.
- Okay.
- Tell me what's on your mind.
- And then I'll try to
get you a date in January,
when I actually have openings.
- Man, that's awesome.
- Awesome, man.
- Really appreciate you,
really, thank you very much.
- Good luck to you, brother, take care.
Brand wins every time.
And they're kissing cousins,
like, all the skills
that make somebody great
at something that we would
all argue is on the other
side of their tracks,
it's the same shit.
That's why I love talking to kids in,
like, urban, underprivileged demos.
I'm like, dude, the
same way you sell weed,
is the same way you can build
a 100 million dollar company.
It's the same fucking game.
The same way my friend sold
fucking CD's from the back of,
it's the same game, it's just (clicks).
The framework, right?
And the same way, whether it's courses or
offers or whatever it is, it's (clicks).
And it's patience.
And really, you guys have the advantage
because you can wait a little bit longer
because you've got something in place.
So, there's a very intriguing
time to make that jump.
Hire every discipline.
Tomorrow, have written content every day,
audio content, your podcast will kill.
- [Business Woman] Yeah.
- And again, remember?
Watch what I'm doing, not what I'm saying.
Clearly, it's like you
said, a lots taken from me.
Why did I care about my
podcast and rebranded the
audio experience, like,
why did that happen.
Not for my health.
It's because I believed in the medium.
And since I rebranded,
now I'm a top hundred
podcast without ever doing a podcast.
Don't hire for skill, or
don't train for skill.
Train for mindset.
Make sure when you start
adding people that, you know,
Iris, why am I hot on Iris?
To give her a compliment.
I think she's got skills,
but when I look at her
and watch her, she has
intuitive communication skills
which can be deployed against anything.
When you have the taste, you
can be the chef of any meal,
if you have the mindset
to be open to not saying
you not just a sous chef
of sushi, but you can also
be a classically trained French
chef as long as you're open.
So please, please, please,
first and, this is the most
important thing I can tell
you, as you start evolving,
it's about being open and
nimble and excited about change,
which is a very rare
commodity for an employee.
Because they were taught
garner a skill and trade on it.
If you're talking about
what I'm up to, which is
fucking all-time, it's in
those subtle fucking margins.
- On your point on that, too, like,
after all the presentations
you've had so far today,
I was going to go out and
hire for the five skill
team members that I need
in order to chop up and do
killer content and all that kind of stuff,
instead of, again this is
the value of the nuance
and the detail of talking
to people who've done it,
and played the game, and they go no.
Go and hire for the
attitude, for the kid who's
hungry enough to want to work for you
for free throughout the year, that's,
and they'll get the skill anyway.
- The skill is a commodity.
The mindset is everything.
(mellow music)
(laughing)
- Emily, appropriately,
realized that "see ya" and
"got it" is the same
exact thing, actually.
Of that, am I doing Nate and
Trout after this tonight?
Okay, can you put that in the schedule?
Holy shit, I flew back from
Singapore with that dude.
He's an architect.
He's just some random guy.
- [Emily] That's awesome.
- That was super weird.
(laughing)
(mellow music)
- Hi.
- Welcome to (mumbles)
- Thank you.
- Hi.
- How are you?
- Emily. Awesome.
- This is cool.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- I love it.
Is failure important?
- On a bigger macro, patience and failure,
they all ladder up to one
thing, which is insecurity.
The reason people don't put
themselves in a position
to fail, the reason people aren't patient,
is they value other
people's opinions too much,
which then dictates their behavior,
which then gets into all of this.
Realize, is if you don't hold on to it
with the thought of in case it fails,
because you just need to realize
it's your scarlet letter.
Literally the reason people are scared,
always, is the outside force.
Having a failing business
and everyone's like, oh see,
you could never do, or whatever
the cliche shit is, right?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, yeah.
- It just doesn't fucking matter.
You know why?
So that's one piece.
- [Interviewer] But they
told me I couldn't do this.
- And even if it didn't succeed,
what, they're such better people?
Like what, I'm such a better person than
other people because I
can build a business?
That's bullshit.
- [Interviewer] But it's not listening
to other people (mumbles).
- That's it.
If you told me, it's too big to fail,
I'm like, that makes sense.
But if you also told
me four years from now,
it doesn't play, I'm like
okay, Lyft, or Google,
or Apple, or (mumbles), like, I don't feel
like it's too big to fail.
First of all, I don't think
anybody's too big to fail.
The only company that I
could say I feel 100% is here
in ten years is Amazon and Facebook,
if Mark and Bezos are running it.
- [MC] Our amazing
speaker, Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience applauds)
- Yo, yo.
Thanks for coming out.
Jesus, what's up?
Like those seats up there.
- What are some of the
things that do keep you going
and motivate you and pushes you?
- Gratitude, 100% gratitude.
The fact that I'm even a human being.
I don't want to be a rhinoceros.
(audience laughing)
Seriously, like, what do
you think's going on here?
No, I mean it, I take
shit in a super-macro.
Like, I'd much rather be me than
this fucking ugly green carpet.
(laughing)
Kidding, I just wanted to
make a joke about the carpet.
(laughing)
I love green, I love green,
I make my shoes green.
Like, but you know what, you know,
like, what's the alternative?
Like, being blessed with
the, you know, I love this
400 trillion-to-one, I
know some of you know it.
Like, so you've been blessed
with a life, I get it.
You weren't born into a rich
family, you're the wrong
skin tone, you're this, you're, I get it.
But, fuck, we got the at bat.
You won the lotto, you won
it, you got the at bat.
Do something with it.
Especially now, your
grandparents didn't have this.
The internet is crazy shit, it just is.
It just is.
And so, why do you think
everybody's getting outed now?
Because three old white guys don't
control the media any more.
The fuck do you think is happening here?
This is the greatest
era ever, for anybody.
The market, the platform is the internet,
this is unbelievable, unprecedented times.
We will look back at this
two hundred years from now,
like, these fuckers
had a good opportunity.
This is buying, do you know
somebody bought the land
that we're on right now
for a dollar at one point?
That's what's happening
with us on the internet.
The attention of the end
consumer is cheap right now.
You can grab it around whatever the fuck
you want to be about, and it doesn't
cost you anything other than your time.
And so many of you are
complaining, but then are
too fancy to put in the
15 hours a day to get it.
I got no respect for that.
I got no respect for anybody who complains
and isn't putting in the work.
Because it's an excuse to not do.
(audience applauds)
And let me tell you, on
this issue, and I see some
of you get it, you can
trick 99% of the losers,
but you're not tricking the 1%.
So, the only people
listening to your bullshit
are the other losers in your circle.
It's truth.
Straight fucking facts to the face.
(audience applauds)
Only person listening
to your bullshit are the
people you surround yourself
that are losers too.
Don't complain, nobody's
listening, nobody that matters.
Your mom has to listen.
(audience laughing)
But let me give you an update, she thinks
you're a loser too.
(audience laughing)
I just want to try to buy the Jets
way more than buying the Jets.
Like, if I pull this shit
off, shits gonna get crazy.
(laughing)
Like, and it's cray because I
really feel like I'm going to.
Like, I laugh at how much I
actually think, forget about,
listen, to amass the wealth
to do it is ironically
funny to me, that's the part
that I'm most confident about.
I'm most confident that
I'll have the money.
It's, does that time well
when the Johnson family
wants to sell it, what
happens in culture, like,
forget about all, forget
about making the money.
The fact that I have the
audacity and the optimism that
not only will I amass the
wealth, but that specific team.
Like, I don't want the
Bengals, you know, like?
(laughing)
So, it's so crazy how
it plays out in my head.
But here's the best part, and
you'll be there to see it,
if I don't, I'm having so
much fun and so much happiness
trying to get it, and
trying to pull all of you up
along the way while I'm trying to get it.
Fuck, if one of you get
it, I would love that
because then it would happen
on merit, you were good enough.
The thought that maybe the
next owner was built from
something I created would be
so batshit crazy, you know?
And I've also got a super
secret plan, and I'll
share it here today for the first time.
(audience laughing)
I figure if I can get every
single person in America
to really give a fuck
about me getting the Jets,
that when they become
available, if I'm not ready
financially, I'm going to crowd
source the fuck out of it.
(audience laughing)
- Being the Gary that you are today.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And you could face
yourself 25 years ago.
- [Gary] Talk to my 17 year old self.
- Yeah, if you could say
something to yourself
for only ten seconds, what would it be?
- You're gonna be right.
(audience applauds)
You know?
That's what I would say, man.
I did everything the way I want.
I'm so proud of how I did this.
And I haven't even started,
but like, I ate shit, like
I just don't, you know,
you just don't get it.
You will only get it if you know somebody
that knows me during that time.
You'll only know me if you
know somebody I went to
high school with and they'll tell you that
every weekend of my entire
fucking high school life,
all of them, I worked 13 hours a day.
That every fucking summer vacation day,
when everybody did shit and
went to the Jersey shore
and hooked up, I fucking worked.
You'll only know if you
actually saw my tax return
only ten years ago, because I
didn't make any fucking money
because I was building a
legacy, doing the right thing,
building, building skills, being patient.
I only give advice that I took.
I only eat my own dog food.
And so, I would tell him,
you're gonna do it right.
Thank you guys.
(audience applauds)
I just want to see how good I can be.
I don't know how else to say, man.
I've only known this game, you know?
I just want to see how good I can do.
I like building businesses, I like,
you know deploying my thoughts.
I feel like my intent is in a good place.
I feel good about myself,
I feel good about it.
And it's curiosity.
Like, I love working, I
love producing impact,
I love producing products,
I love challenging
myself to seeing how well I do understand
culture and attention and the game.
Like, it runs the gamete.
And I want to build the
infrastructure for all the
things that matter for me
in the next 40 years, right?
So, it's just playing the game.
Hey, thank you guys, thank you.
- Drive safe.
- Thank you.